bien que mer
en souvenir non pas du gala de vivre
jusque là qu'elle a dû y aura lieu le 12
mars
1965 mais en souvenir du déjeuner qui
annoncent gala devenu un traitement
brillant et permet de vous offrir une
médaille comme
va le théâtre non pas la toile voilà qu
ont les mêmes raisons
mais l'aïe ajouté ahmed aida
le président américan d'après gré
très jeune il encore merci rejette
je suis à la hauteur de la situation car
m quant à brax la médaille commémorative
à ces jumelages de la vitalité de nos
frais qui a été vous savez citoyens de
diar chantant l'hymne entrer directement
en prison commence à bien puisque déjà
il y à 837 place de luri jean paul
belmondo vous êtes présentent des
facteurs comment ça va se passer le gaz
d'union arba j'espère très bien comme
chaque année tu vas voir des gros
numéros et ils sont pas encore tous au
point mais pour le moment il ya 400 ans
un beau numéro piccoli on sait faire un
numéro de lyon
malheureusement je serai en malaisie
alors peut-être qu'avec un duplex je
ferai un numéro retransmis de là bas et
que sera son bureau mais je sais pas
encore je voir avec de la mare vous avez
une petite idée quand même non non mais
comme là bas en chine j'ai pas mal il ya
des acrobaties à faire alors peut-être
que je me servirai 10 de ses acrobaties
vous avez vous
pensé et vous avez prendre aux sources
voilà on va essayer le temps quand même
encore